le concept choc autorise ses maîtres sur
un seul et même site à lacaune activités
agricoles une activité de transformation
l'activité de distribution l'activité
touristique donc une intégration
verticale à toute la filière
la dernière trouvaille des frères
losilla le choc au tourisme pour ne pas
disparaître pour dynamiser un secteur
qui a redémarré il ya tout juste 15 ans
sous l'impulsion des deux frères
chocolatiers du lamentin entre autres
des agriculteurs se sont remis à planter
et on parle désormais d'excellence pour
la fève et pour le chocolat de notre île
avec ce projet de choco tourisme il
s'agirait de prendre un nouveau virage
mais le projet est onéreux d'où l'idée
d'une souscription populaire
nous n'avons pas les solides aujourd'hui
friends et à nous sommes vraiment à bout
de souffle la partie financière nous
avons beaucoup investi sont allés
vraiment sous nos propres deniers et
pour aller faire ce projet il faut
absolument que l'on ait ce soutien ce
soutien populaire plus la martinique
sera avec nous plus elle sera derrière
nous tout ce projet sera exceptionnel
une souscription via une plateforme
électronique
but de l'opération recueillir 200 mille
euros pour débloquer d'autres fonds
auprès des banques
le projet final tournerait autour d'un
peu plus de 2 millions d'euros
en attendant les frères l'osella seul
initiateurs du projet prospects il
recherche un terrain entre 5 et 10
hectares propice à la culture du cacao
et à l'accueil du public à la clé
distille autour de 500 emplois pour le
secteur